we're joined now by our chief elections
and campaign correspondent that's robert
costa bob good morning i thought of you
often last night watching this we the
president says this is a fake hearing
but we should remind our viewers that
the testimony and the evidence is coming
from former members of the president's
administration these are republicans
these are conservatives these are
supporters of many of the other policies
that the administration poured forward
and i think the theme last night was
closeness how close the vice president
came to encountering the mob how scared
his security detail was and how the the
president himself could have walked just
a few steps and and called off the mob
in the white house briefing room and did
not that's what stood out to me what
stood out to you as you were watching
last night
tony good morning such an important
point it was revealed last night how
close american democracy came to not
functioning to not carrying on on the
night of january 6. footage from a
secure location showed congressional
leaders democrats and republicans
huddled around a phone talking to the
acting secretary of defense wondering
was the capital able to be secured it
was an open question that night about
whether this whole thing the
certification of a presidential election
would happen all while the president sat
idle at the white house watching
television in the dining room
it's such a major
fact that you just put forward that
american democracy itself was threatened
and the point was made last night that
the threat continues followers of the
former president continue to believe the
current president is illegitimate and
that violence would be justified to
overthrow him so i hate to bring this to
politics but what does last night's
evidence and the committee's work to
this point mean for the next election
and the election after that
tony the committee knows that ultimately
it will be up to the justice department
to attorney general merrick garland to
define whether all of this evidence is a
criminal case against former president
trump and they have not made a decision
on that front yet but they do believe
the committee does that they can define
trump as a president who was
abandoning his post a president who was
sitting there for hours as the capital
was attacked did not do his duty as
commander in chief and that's why they
believe these hearings are important and
they know that some voters might not be
paying attention but they do believe
they're breaking through because in
their view talking to members talking to
people close to the committee facts are
facts and when people see the images
they hear the sounds those chilling
phone calls from members of vice
president pence's detail they hope they
believe that perhaps they will sit up
and wonder should their assumptions
their thoughts about all this be changed
should they reevaluate if they're
especially a republican what happened
i want to pick up two bob about those
those texts that was so startling to me
that you could hear the secret service
who were trained in this kind of thing
you could see that they were very
concerned people even use the word that
they were scared about what was
happening
happening that night so much so that
they were calling their family members
to say that this could be it why do you
think that was important to include and
what did you make of that we had heard
that was something we had never heard
before
it was something that highlighted gail
how what happened on january 6 was not
just a crisis in democracy it was a
national security crisis the vice
president of the united states steps
away from people who had broken into the
capitol building were not wanted in any
way to see whether they had firearms
they might have been carrying they might
have had the intention to commit
violence and those secret service agents
knew as this evidence shows that this
was a very dangerous perilous situation
to have someone who's next in line to
the presidency to be so close to
violence that's unpredictable and they
also knew that this was a moment for the
country where the whole world was
watching while the president was
watching tv the world was watching the
united states wondering who was in
charge what was going on
and that the president never called his
vice president when he knew he was in
danger to say are you okay what is
happening to you
oh it's been very startling indeed in
their constitutional questions vice
president pence had to effectively serve
as commander-in-chief for hours trying
to get the national guard activated
well we do know these hearings have
opened up the eyes to the american
people on what happened on a very very
dark day bob thank you